all right dennis
dennis so where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
brooklyn new york um
daika heights very good neighborhood you
know um
my mother my father my brother you know
a dog very much
picture perfect i mean as far as
my childhood goes with the exception of
my older brother i mean i had a
wonderful childhood wonderful family
a lot of love um
you know
really nothing negative
and then when you get to my brother
there's every kind of abuse you could
possibly imagine to the point where it
was like uh
living with freddy krueger
so your relationship with your brother
was was not ideal yeah i mean at this
point it's barely civil high and bi we
text each other on birthdays and that's
about it
he was physically abusive
when i was 12 he was walking the dog i
followed him on a bike and he had six of
his friends kick the [ __ ] out of me
you know
you
hit all my girlfriends or you know girls
that i was talking to
just as
emotionally and physically abusive as
you could possibly get
um you know funny part is he hated the
fact that i got involved in drugs but
he's the one who gave me my first joint
um
and he's also
in my opinion an undiagnosed alcoholic
so you know who's the pot and who's the
cattle
with your childhood with your friend
with your family was good was it was
excellent you know i couldn't have
gotten more love couldn't have gotten
more support you know parents both
wonderful people
my mom was a teacher my father worked a
lot um very close-knit extended family
grandparents aunts uncles cousins
um
really couldn't have asked for better um
you know just
wonderful people and you've had jobs
i have had jobs i started when i was 16
17 humping cases in a liquor store
and then i wound up managing that same
store
and the
that kind of turned into a nice career i
was able to catch on with one of the
distributors as a i started as a
merchandiser and then i wound up a
salesman by the time i was 24 25 i was
making about 180 000 a year
um
you know for somebody who possibly has
addiction issues
beverage alcohol
probably not the best business to be in
but
by the time i was 31 32 that kind of
came to a screeching halt i had gotten a
dwi and
they allowed me to resign
and that was the last
corporate
career type job i've had
i have been a personal trainer
i lived in florida for a number of years
so that was the bulk of my business that
and a boxing instructor
that went very very well
and other than that i mean just bouncing
around phone rooms and
you know
odds and ends menial jobs and then
of course you know hustling you know uh
somebody gets a prescription flip it for
them or you know
picking stuff up for people i mean
there's there's always ways to make a
decent buck did the harder drug use
start after
you lost your job
i think the harder drug use contributed
to the loss of a job
to the loss of my career
but yeah definitely i mean at that point
i don't even think i had shot up yet
because uh after the after the career i
went to florida
and moved into a halfway house
and
that was where i shot up the first time
my uh my friend kenny who since has
overdosed and died
uh he didn't want to do it begged me not
to you know i didn't understand that at
the time
and
now i understand that like i i would eat
a bullet before i introduced somebody to
that monster um
you know and
i i fell in love with it instantly
and as soon as i discovered opiates in
the needle
that was when it stopped being fun you
know prior to that it was pot it was x
it was coke on the weekends drinking you
know i mean always excessive but
uh
at least controlled hidden or you know
um wasn't painfully obvious but with the
opiates it got very obvious very quick
and it stopped being fun it was i
discovered my true love and from right
out the window became you know
uh something that
almost like my existence was devoted to
it
so you smoke hair or you inject heroin
but it's is it heroin is it fentanyl
these days i don't think you could find
heroin without fentanyl um i'm sure
there's fentanyl in there i've never
tested it i would be shocked if there
wasn't
um
what is the
what does you put you mix it with crack
yeah i uh my typical shot involves uh
two to three twenty's a crack and maybe
a half a bundle which is like five bags
of heroin
you know i uh dilute it with vinegar to
get the chemical you know to neutralize
the chemicals in the crack
and i inject it
and the combination of those two they're
almost opposite drugs
uh they are but they do complement each
other in a way i mean uh with cocaine
you end up zipping around you know um
crack cocaine you end up zipping around
you're like uh like the roadrunner
and with heroin you know i always tell
people it's like somebody cracks an egg
on your forehead and it just kind of
droops down with this warm fuzzy you
know i love everything feeling
that's um
almost euphoric but
um you know one takes the edge off the
other and they do complement each other
very well in that regard you know um
it's like a lot of times you see people
who are just straight dopers
you know and they're drooling or the the
term we use is oh we're going to be
sucking his own deck you know you
hunched over like that and
um that
doesn't happen so it's like you're
conscious enough to actually enjoy
the high
and how do you support yourself
i mean there's there's always a lot of
hustles you know um thankfully my family
is um you know they help out where they
can
um
you know every now and then i'll you
know come up with a job somebody needs
something done you know uh
wants something like that but a lot of
wheeling and dealing you know uh who's
got a prescription for 130 roxies okay
pick it up for 18 dump it for 26.
you know that kind of thing
people
wanting product and not knowing where to
go so you know get that for them and
they had 20 percent
um
you know
a lot of hustles a lot of running around
and i mean honestly half the time i
don't know how the hell i fund my habit
i got almost a 300 a day habit i have no
idea how the hell i come up with the
money sometimes and having a habit like
this you must have some crazy stories of
uh
yeah you could say that
you could say that um
i'm actually one of the few people that
could say the crack saved their life
i had when i was in florida at one point
i'd gotten very low and i decided i
wanted to check out so i took about two
hundred dollars worth of dope and i put
it in a rig
i said you know what just for good
measure i threw a 50 a crack in there
about four hours later i came to
thinking that hell looked a lot like the
hotel room that i was you know shooting
up in the night before
and uh then i realized that the crack
probably kept my heart pumping and saved
my life
you know
there was another time i coded out in
the hospital i was there for a shoulder
surgery went in the bathroom to boot up
you know and came by with some stuff
and i coded out and took a ride on the
flat line
and i remember to this day this actually
scared me
like i can't even tell you how much um
but when i was coming too
it wasn't you know they had me on the
the wooden thing with the they were
trying to get that orange [ __ ] around my
head and
i started flying like a fish out of
water because
coming out of that when they gave me the
narcan i didn't see people
i mean a lot of people i guess see
different things the mind hallucinates
or whatever it is but it
it looked like demons to the point where
i started flailing around big time and
fighting them and one of the nurses told
me it took like 11 of them to hold me
down
and get me to stop moving around like
that
but then
you know that kind of
meshed back into reality not long after
you know maybe 30 seconds a minute after
and i realized what was going on
and um you know
and that was it so they kept me for an
extra two days prior to the surgery
and yeah thankfully i was in the
hospital when i coded though because it
turns out even though i tried attempting
suicide once i'm not that keen to go
how do you think your years of living
this lifestyle have changed you
um
you know you start out
and you have a clear sense of who you
are what you'll do what you won't do
and then
you know something happens and one thing
doesn't seem wrong
and another thing doesn't seem wrong
and another thing doesn't seem wrong and
even though there are certain lines that
you you don't cross in places that you
just won't go
you know you almost wind up not being
able to recognize yourself
you know it's it's almost like uh i was
told if it's almost like a washing
machine you know you just over and over
and you get your head up for a little
bit of air and then it's right back down
to the bottom and you know um
as much as i hate the godfather iii just
when i thought i was out they pulled me
back in that kind of thing you know
it definitely takes a toll and it leaves
you with a self-image that resembles
probably what you would scrape off the
bottom of your boot or sheet form
you know
i don't have a high opinion of myself in
any way shape or form i mean you know i
i don't believe addiction is not really
a drug problem i think it's a self-worth
problem
i agree
to a point i think the one common factor
that i've found in everybody that deals
with addiction is some major type of
trauma along the lines of heartache
betrayal you know um
that's very deeply rooted in their
belief system about themselves or at
least that's how it is for me and that's
what i've experienced but i agree
wholeheartedly i don't think that drugs
are the problem
for anybody that does drugs i think they
do drugs because that's the solution
and the problem lays within that
you know self-worth yeah
and for your in your case it was your
brother yeah
yeah my brother and my my uh my first
love actually who or the love of my life
to this day i i wish i never met her but
she's the love of my life
there was nothing i wouldn't have done
for her
broke me up into a million pieces
um
definitely secondary to my brother but
there
nonetheless
but heartache trauma and
you know the uh resulting self-worth
that comes from that a lack thereof
perfect recipe for addiction
you spend time in jail or prison
i have been to county jail in florida i
spent four months
first time i got arrested was three
pills
wound up going to drug court which i
mean they they set you up to fail they
might as well just you know
do away with the program because
you're going back in i think they have a
graduation rate of like eight percent so
um
you know i wound up violating
i dropped out of that and then i
violated probation with another
possession charge and it was go to jail
go directly to jail do not pass go
that was in broward county
now it's funny they have the highest
recidivism rate in the country and the
second busiest jail
um
only to second only to las vegas
uh they have four jails two prison runs
a week and
one pill was what put me back in there
for four months
which i mean you know what i've gotten
away with so much you almost can't even
get mad it's almost just like okay you
know what fine you got me on something
and
that's that's how i kept myself from
getting better um
you know because when i get better then
a lot more bad things can happen
you know what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
oh boy
there's a few that i really can't place
above
the others
you know
you know it really sucks when you learn
that it's always a friend that hates you
the most
that there's nobody that wouldn't hurt
you if it would help them
you know
obviously excluding family and most you
know in a lot of cases or most cases or
healthy cases whatever the hell that
means
you know um
[Music]
it just it makes you feel very
alone
you know
inconsequential
and that's
not a good thing feeling that isolated
from everything
because it makes the self-destructive
behavior a lot easier
you know um
i i really hate the fact that
hindsight's 20 20 but
um you know i'm sure everybody has the
uh time machine scenario in their head
there's really with all the stupid
things that i've done all the times i
went left that i wish i should own right
if i could go back
to when i was 14 15 there's only one
thing that i would change
only one
i would listen
with
blind obedience
to absolutely every syllable suggestion
idea like
anything and everything that my parents
ever said
with blind obedience
you know
without question that's the only thing i
would change
what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear oh boy
um
my biggest fear is that this is it
you know
um
that it's just this
shallow hollow existence
you know kind of limping on until you
wind up six feet on the you know um
however you get there which i mean in
this life there's more than one way
uh
none of them
fun
but uh that that this is all there is
that there's not more i mean look if if
somebody could wave a wand then i could
stop tomorrow
i i would
do it in a heartbeat but
you know they talk about okay you got in
trouble you went in you did your thing
you know you paid your debt to society
but that's that's complete and total
[ __ ] because when i got out i was
gung-ho i was going to conquer the world
i was going to get back into the you
know into the workforce and
you continue to pay your debt every time
you fill out a job application there's a
lot of places that say they hire felons
you know and they get their tax breaks
and all but they have a certain number
that they have to carry on but then
finding places that say they do things
that's one thing finding places that
actually do them
you know or do it for more than a quota
for a tax break that's another story
altogether so i'm still paying that debt
and for what
for for possession of four pills
i didn't shoot anybody i didn't you know
siphon millions of dollars out of
somebody's bank account or anything else
i mean it was
like
a possession charge and it's following
me
with everything that i try to do so
how many times can you beat your head
against that wall or against that door
and they just you know
go away come back another time or can't
do it because this is you know something
that happened years ago i mean how long
until you just kind of get fed up and
give up and retreat to what you know you
know and in this case it's when the
plunger goes down
doesn't matter what's going on
everything goes away
nothing else matters no
is that what the heroin does it just
helps
make everything feel all right yeah it's
um
and then the crack two to a degree it
you know it numbs everything out but it
uh
it just whatever's going on that layer
of [ __ ] that's always eating away at
you whatever your your worries your
stresses are it's just totally on the
back burner and everything is all
[Music]
fuzzy roses and
dandelion fields and you could really
give a [ __ ] about anything because it
just all
goes away it's like like i said earlier
that egg cracks it's just like
and
it lasts for how long nothing else
matters
uh it depends on the dope i mean look
i've got a heavy habit i burned probably
about 300 a day um you know sometimes i
don't come up with that much but i
generally you know
don't have an issue with uh
with too much of an issue but
sometimes
that initial feeling unfortunately
doesn't last very long but the actual
highway you could just kind of lay back
and
and just kind of be within equilibrium
that you wouldn't have
if
you know you weren't high
it could be anywhere from a half hour to
two three hours depends on the stuff
do you have kids
no no kids
no thankfully no kids never been married
i actually truthfully um a couple of
years ago i i just started assuming that
i was shooting blanks because the fact
that i never
got that phone call um
amazed me
what was the lowest point in your life
or is this it now oh boy
um
lois i mean like watching my mother die
was um was very difficult but that
wasn't about me that was about her
um
lowest point in my life my father and i
were getting into it
i mean this was all of a few seconds but
it was by far the most impactful
um
you know we were going back and forth
heated discussion regarding addiction
and some of the things that i was you
know doing to myself
and he said to me you know first he was
yelling and then he said to me in a very
calm voice which i mean anybody who's
ever had a heated discussion with their
father once that voice gets calm you
kind of know
there's a bomb about to drop and he said
to me i'm i'm ashamed that you have the
same name i do
and
that
i don't think i ever felt like a bigger
piece of [ __ ]
than in that moment
you know um
i mean i had uh
another guy who owned a halfway house
tell me at one point
that
i was the best and worst he had ever met
as far as addicts go and i was actually
stupid enough to take that as a
compliment
but um
you know not long after he said you know
you're a vicious vicious drug addict
and
you know
by far
the
worst i've ever seen
in that regard and that
that didn't feel good like even this
doing this whole interview you know um
i mean i know you have this uh thing
going with youtube you blow up you know
you're blowing up and
a lot of people see it and the only time
anybody wants to hear from me or
anything about my story is about the
absolute worst
that has gone on in my life the things
that i've done to myself to others that
that doesn't feel good you know that um
that's what
somebody
wants to know about or somebody's asking
about the the thing that you try and
keep you know in the back of the closet
so nobody else could see
you know and um
yeah that what do you think would turn
it around for you what do you think
would possibly get you to
put the drugs down and
straighten them you know i only had
success with it
and anytime
i put the drugs down
the focus always went from drugs to not
being on drugs
problem was
whether he focuses on doing them or not
doing them your focus is still on drugs
you know i had success at a christian
rehab
um but then you get out into the real
world and there's a lack of opportunity
because you're still checking that box
that says felon
you know um
[Music]
but again the only success i ever had
was just going back to a real life
with you know um
a career opportunity or you know
a job i mean i i would need an
opportunity
to really
you know if somebody would give me a
chance um
i mean
look it's with no ego that i say this
but so many people have told me that if
i could just put my energy and focus
into something positive that it would
almost be scary and that's
you know i
i hate what i do i hate myself for doing
it but
it's so much easier to keep doing it
because there's no opportunity for any
different because it's still just that
box
you know
do you have a felony you know it's my
entire [ __ ] life paid my debt to
society my ass every time i fill out a
job application
you know people aren't lining up to hire
guys like me